we're all in a good place and I'm happy  well things may have changed for blac  Chyna and Rob Kardashian as since we  caught up with the mom-to-be in June a  source close to Rob tells ET the couple  is quoted not in a good place right now  are they still together if you ask Rob  he'll say they're having issues if you  ask the China she'll say they are not  together it's difficult to put a  definition on it our source says the  pregnancy TV show and Rob's return to  the public I was kind of the perfect  storm of pressure for the 29 year old as  we'll see on the next new episode of  Robin China he's still not used to being  around even his one-time of close  friends they keep calling me like why  have I not met Rob suture wife and  mother of his child and I'm like I don't  know what to do and I tell Rob but he's  it's like  while our source says rob is in a bad  place right now they add that the  chances of him and China getting back  together are pretty high